[Laughter]
leave your intravenous already closed an
episode of why welcome back everybody
clap it up to YouTube's favorite show
have I mentioned by the way about this
chair I know probably some of you have
seen it before but you know the rundown
Italian leather well designed I never
really showed like the bottom of it like
if you show down at it if I got you you
have to leave a like on this video right
now guys if you're new here we like to
have fun on this channel we're just
laughing around it's nothing serious so
there's no reason to be upset we're just
having a good time everybody that's what
that's the spirit of love why just
having fun and like embracing life and
such it's great is that porn mom no it's
a horror game mmm if I was the mom I
would send that kid straight into
rehabilitation rehab is what I'm trying
to say cuz there's no way my son my own
flesh and blood would pick Natsuki s
favorite girl disgusting from a hot dog
seller to a chair Sadler isn't it great
following my journey here on this
channel guys not just my channel growth
but also my personal growth as well it's
fun to look back sometimes I think we're
better I mean worse when you see pewds
mouse pad it's so effing big that's
right a lot of people have been calling
me out saying oh really oh really then
what is this
[Music]
guys we'd like to have fun on this
channel it's all about having great the
time and just having fun it's all he
predicted it we are all going oh no oh
no oh Sumi must say hulking summer
Sumi Masen he has no legs climbs Everest
what is your excuse his legs won't hurt
mine will ya bride number one what is
this treason no that is Ian Busch Brad
doesn't get paid enough by Peter pine so
he can't afford the chair that's right
that's right he doesn't get I mean yeah
that's right so he has to settle for
that the court that the class underneath
instead of getting a Ferrari he got a
Nissan 2012 2018 he took me six years to
grow of didn't pubic bead cuz poopy is
switched in Viking God that's why he
grows his beard so effort at
effortlessly yeah yeah this has
definitely been completely without any
effort whatsoever it has not been a
psychological challenge looking in the
mirror every day is thinking why is
there dead cat on my face so many people
asked like what is that thing in the
reflection of advices and there you go
Flat Earth the nurse needs to be wake
the [ __ ] up Chris the earth is a donut
and the donut is in my office oh my god
oh my god don't worry we just we're just
having a good time here we're just
having a good time fun laughing and
under no circumstances should you ever
hit a woman spank me Kenny no I'm proud
of you son
respect women for deep pie what is this
a video oh my god I bet you're jealous
haters won't guess what no I got two of
them sub down [ __ ]
the drop i was the best 5-6 you will pay
for this you mom gay no you your dad
life spin you granny trainee your sister
Fister you say it has gone too far I
know I think that's that's far enough
it's the right way to put it I posted
this two days ago and it got a bunch of
off post but didn't get on the low I so
I reposted it okay come on we got to get
out
I keep thinking about this story there's
this video that kills you seven days
after you watch it the second it's over
the phone rings and this boy says and
now no one is safe
the closet man alright fine that was
actually amazing I'm sorry I didn't see
it earlier too good to be in the way
wow we are now entering that the middle
means the metal man of memes everybody
the second page these spot the
differences are getting harder when you
are adopted by a lesbian couple and
someone says your mom
hard to swallow pills beautifies editors
are funnier than he is oh really when
why don't we see they'll make a great
joke then that's right that's right my
point proving what the hell is this what
just happened did he throw it I closet
that look like mine or something great
when Pierce gives a meme zero out of ten
but you think it's pretty dank and
realized you are enormous I mean you're
all normies this whole sub is Normie 85%
of reddit is Normie 90% of memes are
Normie sayin Normie is Normie I'm so
cool and dank i if you think so
otherwise you're uh Normie xdd is Normie
gay is normal your mom Normie I'm really
proud of you guys yes I'm vegan yes I
eat meat we exist yes I die yes we
exists be a good editor yeah well
and it videos for the most subscribed
youtuber getting bullied by peopIe what
are you gonna do Savi gonna cry
ubi you no one cares you put me and be
[Laughter]
YouTube 2016 all good normal ad revenue
YouTube 2017 all videos are demonetized
bad ad revenue YouTube 2018 videos
become negative monetized users have
money
forced taken from them YouTube 2019 all
revenue is distributed equally uh among
all creators uses that breakaway the
guidelines are sent to good some hi fish
boys but I wish I could just say it do
you know how frustrating it is to not be
able to swear peers upload a gaming
video it's only for 25 have really gone
so far that has we've gone from
complaining that the videos are too long
to now complaining that they're not ten
minutes is that really where we are in
this community really I'm blank no
you're not I'm funny no you're not I'm
original yes I am your MCM says but can
you do this but does he ever say but can
I do this for you I might delete this
before it ends up on Reddit and PT pi
reacts to it and bullies me again
oh no no why would I bully here that was
such a great joke everybody give him a
round of applause
longtime fan love your toy bid used to
design toys so I thought I'd make one of
you that is so cool what are you kidding
me that beard is beautiful the three
pain levels painful very painful no
bonus me the truest suffering of them
are maybe next week guys upload to have
pity power reactor Peter Pan reacting to
PewDiePie reacting to a Peter Pi video
stop all right just stop that's all I'm
gonna say
I sold the ad pocalypse make the video 5
minutes long slow down the video half
speed so it becomes 10 minutes upload
make everyone watch the video in 10 -
times speed on YouTube hmm
I actually want to try this should we do
that do it right now see if this works
all right Brad is floating down the
video when you hear a Japanese word and
you understand it without needing some
title I sent this to my Sega's it's so
true when you win the lottery and your
girl says we want your twitter is now
equivalent overshooting Facebook mean
page oh wow what a great burn I really
stink isn't that it's obvious it's
obvious that that's the case jack and
it's obvious that you want it to be your
case as well - stop crying oh my god I
wish my setup look that good damn that
looks tight boom cake 1 million points
you will get 1 million bro points enjoy
that when Felix hasn't made it to 10
minutes
alright guys leave it like if you
enjoyed this video and remember can you
do this
[Music]
gotcha